[Music]
good morning
class of 2023 transfer students Eli
Whitney students and visiting
international students welcome to you
I am Marvin Chun Dean of Yale College
and I'm so pleased to be with you here
that on this beautiful morning joining
me on stage to greet you our president
Peter salivate Provost Ben Pollock
secretary Kim goth Cruz Faculty of Arts
and Sciences Dean Tamar Gendler Graduate
School Dean Lynn Cooley athletic
director Vicky Chun the Yale alumni
associations executive director Whaley
Chang officers of the University heads
and Dean's of residential colleges and
Dean's and members of the Yale College
Dean's office
family members and friends who are here
today we extend our warm welcome to you
and we thank you for everything that you
have done to support and guide these
young adults and my role is Dean one of
my job's is to support president
Saliva's mission for Yale to be the
research university most committed to
teaching and learning what that means
for you students is that I am here to
make sure that you get the best of what
Yale has to offer in the classroom or
outside of it a good part of what you
will learn here will come from the
faculty who will teach you in the
classes you will take well much will
come from the people sitting here with
you today your peers and colleagues
taken together these teachers of yours
will give you the liberal education that
is yells hallmark and by the time you
graduate you will have furnished your
mind in the broadest possible sense not
by pursuing narrow specialized study but
instead by searching for new knowledge
new perspectives new ways of looking at
the world and by adding your own if you
make good use of this place you will
discover fields of knowledge that are
completely new to you that you haven't
even heard of and you will open
yourselves to them and learn from them
and when you get to know your colleagues
sitting around here today something else
you will discover is that you come from
every possible walk of life bringing
with you every imaginable talent every
experience every worldview learn from
them too
as a community you are politically
liberal conservative or moderate your
people with and without disabilities you
observe different religions or none
roughly two out of three of you attended
public high schools about one out of
five of you are eligible for Federal
Pell grants over one out of six of you
are first-generation college students
about one out of nine of you are
international students from over 50
countries more than half of you identify
as students of color and you are of all
genders and sexualities we should take
none of this for granted think for a
minute that for most of us history as
recently as fifty years ago even when US
was able to send humans to the moon
women were not allowed to receive an
education in yo college I think of my
mother who along with my late father
immigrated to California from South
Korea now one of the world's most
prosperous countries and here's why I
get to ask how many of you know BTS no
hands raised behind me right South Korea
was one of the poorest countries back
then but even in the 1950s right after a
devastating war my mom was able to
receive a college education from Korea's
version of Yale and without the
opportunities afforded to her I know
that I would not be standing here as a
faculty member of this great place you
were coming to Yale as it marks a
historic milestone the anniversary of 50
years of co-education in Yale College
and 150 years of co-education in the
graduate and professional schools this
year the university honors the
monumental value that co-education has
brought to our institution not only
because co education was such a huge
step forward in creating today's Yale
community but also because it went to
the heart of a Yale liberal education
open to all
people as well as to all ideas you will
hear the word excellent and diversity
together here again and again at Yale
they go hand-in-hand if you look at
Yale's history as its excellence has
continued and grown every decade every
year so has the diversity of its
students staff and faculty
the connection between excellence and
diversity has long captured the
attention of researchers who study
collective intelligence and who
investigate whether groups are smarter
than the individuals in them Carnegie
Mellon management professor Anita
Woolley who studies teams and what makes
them stronger found that it is not the
group's average IQ or even the IQ of its
smartest member and isn't the number it
is not the number of extroverted members
or the group's motivation what she found
and here she is in her own words was
that the individual skills most critical
for collective intelligence are those
that enhance the ability of group
members to collaborate effectively or
the skills that enrich the collaboration
by bringing a sufficient diversity of
perspectives these are the conditions of
collective intelligence and what they do
is they predict a group's
superior performance on a wide range of
complex tasks this could mean playing
checkers brainstorming possible uses of
a brick optimizing choices and
behavioral economic games or even
competing in league of legends Yale
embraces the idea of collective
intelligence which depends on people who
bring diverse ways of looking at the
world and who know how to communicate
and collaborate and here you are you
have earned a place in this community
which is itself a team because of the
promise you have shown in what you will
contribute to it and to the communities
and teams you will join after you
graduate and as you think about how to
do that you can start by asking how to
maximize your collective intelligence by
leveraging
different backgrounds views talents and
interests and how you can enhance your
social sensitivity as a community by
learning how to see the world through
each other's eyes as a psychology
professor let me demonstrate one way you
might start out on this road and so here
please I'll pull out your printed
program and inside you'll find an insert
take it out and you'll see the one the
insert with a big image in it on it okay
so look at the image the first image on
the top okay and then name out loud when
I say go what you see okay
go good thank you if you first saw a
duck raise your hand okay and if you
first saw a rabbit raise your hand okay
half half are pretty evenly split right
and then now you can try seeing it both
ways if you saw it as a duck try to see
it as a rabbit and vice versa if you
have trouble seeing it both ways and one
having trouble seeing it both ways the
Admissions Director is behind me
so this simple demonstration shows a
fundamental principle of psychology that
we all experience the world differently
our perceptual interpretations as in the
case you just saw but also our memories
our thoughts our attitudes are all
constructs of the mind and they differ
across people even when considering the
same object event or evidence Yale will
expose you to views different from your
own and when it does you can start by
finding common ground with people when
you don't agree with them so before you
put away your insert look take one more
look at it this time on the bottom a
cartoon and you can see that there are
two armies facing each other okay think
of us-china trade relations and then
look at the army on the bottom and at
the front of that army on the bottom
there's a general who's looking back at
his troops and he's urging them with the
following comic with a following caption
there can be no peace until they
renounce their rabid God and accept our
duck God okay so imagine what happens
when the opposing troops realize they
are serving the same flag and so you can
ask yourself what is my flag so here's
our final exercise please shout out the
answer to the following your first quiz
at Yale what's the research university
most committed to teaching and learning
please shout it out
you are all now members of Bulldog
Nation with the sophomores juniors and
seniors and alumni faculty and staff and
with each other you have common ground
an immediate shared bond that is more
than tribal it goes deeper to the
intellectual curiosity and the
commitment to community that have all
brought you all here you have arrived at
a place that values difference and
actively seeks it out it is how
professors and students find and test
knowledge and it is how the university
equips its students to become leaders
and citizens of the world but here the
value of seeking difference is even more
than that it is taken as a article of
faith it is the coin of the realm it is
one of the bedrock principles that
governs us in and out of the classroom
and so let me assume that you came here
not only to find knowledge but to live
lives of consequence and if that's true
you have come to the right place and as
you take your first steps then you will
need to become comfortable with
difference not just to accept it or
tolerate it but to insist on it we will
find guides everywhere in the classes
you will take the activities you will
join and most of all again from the
people sitting around you right now your
peers and classmates all of them are
part of the liberal education that
awaits you your life at Yale has started
and in just a few days you'll be
enrolling in classes joining
organizations or training with your
teams and as you do that here's what I
hope you will do if you are a duck
person go find those rabbit people and
find common ground with them if you are
studying all duck courses go find the
rabbit courses and see what they can
teach you and when you find yourself
rallying around a duck flag take a good
hard look at the rabbit flag across the
field and the people rallying around it
and remember that you are all yay Lee's
members of the class of 2023 transfer
students Eli Whitney students visiting
international students you all belong to
Yale and Yale belongs to you welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning
to all Li Whitney's students transfer
students visiting international students
and first-year Yale College students
welcome to you
on behalf of my colleague skier on stage
I extend the warm greeting to the
families here today and thank you all
for joining us please remember these
first moments of your loved ones college
career are very special and I'm glad you
can share them with us today usually in
an opening address university presidents
tell undergraduates that they are
amazing individuals selected from the
among the most talented high school
students in the world today this is of
course true but it is not the point I
want to make instead I want to encourage
you to approach College unimpressed by
how impressive you are have more
questions than answers admit to being
puzzled or confused be willing to say I
don't know but I want to find out and
most important have the courage to say
perhaps I am wrong and others are right
this is how you will learn the most from
your teachers and classmates and this is
why we have all come to this place we
are here to ask questions questions
about one another and about the world
around us we are here at Yale to nurture
a culture of curiosity this summer I
read a story about Isadora Isaak robbing
one of the country's most extraordinary
scientists he remembered an important
question his mother asked him brought to
this country as an infant Robby
conducted research into particle beams
that led to the development
of the MRI and many other scientific
advances and he won the Nobel Prize for
Physics in 1944 Robby's parents ran a
small grocery store in Brooklyn his
mother had no formal education the other
moms he remembered asked their children
every afternoon if they had learned
anything in school not my mother he
recalled she always asked me a different
question is he she would say did you ask
a good question today he believed her
reminder to ask good questions helped
set him on a path to become a
distinguished scientist so to all the
families here today when you call your
Yale students when you ask them about
their classes and their roommates and
the food remember also to ask them about
their questions
imagine all the great discoveries that
have come from asking a question from
Newton's theory of gravity to the
astonishing breakthroughs in quantum
science some of which are happening here
at Yale when a musician experiments with
a new melody or a sociologist observes a
social interaction they ask why and what
would happen if their curiosity lights
up our world and points us in new
directions self discoveries come from
asking questions to what do you learn
when you ask yourself why don't I
believe that why do I believe that or
why did I do that I think of these lines
from the poet Billy Collins
the trouble with poetry is that
encourages the writing of more poetry I
would say the same of asking questions
one leads to another which opens doors
to still another sometimes our questions
lead to a dead end
we realize the question we asked wasn't
quite right and a door closes but along
the way we have learned something
perhaps in the future we will ask better
questions in a well-known scene in the
movie The Pink Panther Inspector
Clouseau checks into a hotel in Germany
he sees a dachshund in the lobby and he
asks the hotel owner does your dog bite
the owner replies know when Clouseau
goes to pet the dog it bites his hand
hard shocked he tells the hotel owner I
thought you said your dog doesn't bite
the owner replies that is not my dog
Inspector Clouseau simply hadn't asked
the right question so years ago I taught
an undergraduate seminar and one of the
questions on the application of the
course was what is the most important
thing you've changed your mind about we
were surprised that quite a few students
reported that they had not changed their
minds about anything at all so we
decided to accept to the class only
students who had changed their minds
about something important be willing to
change your mind ask questions and
embrace yells culture of curiosity be
open to different viewpoints and
experiences see them as opportunities to
learn
even if sometimes you get your hand bit
now I'm a social psychologist then as a
graduate student at Yale my curiosity
was sparked by the study of emotions and
by a question my undergraduate advisor
had asked me Peter why do you think
humans even have emotions what do they
do for us
one of my major areas of research ever
since has been emotional intelligence in
our earliest work we described emotional
intelligence as a set of skills that one
can learn that helps you extract the
information the data contained in
emotions either your own or somebody
else's after a few years of research it
was obvious to me in my collaborators
that we weren't asking exactly the right
question we needed to be able to show
that emotional intelligence predicted
outcomes in life the ability to form
friendships succeed in school work as
part of a teaming and the like trouble
was how do you go about measuring the
skills of emotional intelligence we
asked ourselves a series of questions
starting with well how are personnel how
are personal characteristics typically
measured by psychologists the answer is
by asking people to rate themselves
these are called self reports but this
led to approaches that disappointed us
how would someone know if ever the kind
of person who is especially good at
identifying emotions or understanding
them or managing them or using emotions
perhaps thinking that you had
spectacular emotional intelligence was a
sign of not having much of it at all so
that door closed we asked ourselves
another question if we wanted to know if
someone possessed the skills of a great
baseball player hitting throwing
catching the ball running bases
how confident would we be of self-report
the answer is not very all ballplayers
think they're going to be the next a rod
when I was a child I thought I'd be the
next call you strum ski on the Boston
Red Sox my brother played in the
backyard but in fact I barely got out of
Little League with my pride intact
why would emotional intelligence be any
different than baseball if we wanted to
know whether someone had high e aí we
needed to assess these skills as
abilities and what would an ability
measure of emotional intelligence even
look like so asking ourselves these
questions led to an answer that made
more sense and our ability based measure
of emotional intelligence has now been
used in hundreds of studies knowing that
we didn't have all the answers and
taking an inquisitive curious attitude
allowed us the opportunity to create
something relatively new so what
questions will you ask what will spark
your curiosity
not long ago I received an email from a
very proud yale college parent he told
me about his son who heard 77 different
speakers during his first year at yale
77 he had learned from thinkers and
leaders across the political spectrum he
had attended events organized by a wide
range of campus organizations what a way
to spend the first year could you do
this and not change your mind about
something important and it turns out
this student is also very good at asking
questions he's doing a project where in
the past year he has interviewed dozens
of people scholars and activists and
journalists and entrepreneurs from many
different sectors
like so many students faculty and staff
he is nurturing a culture of curiosity
at Yale
indeed the Yale is who have come before
you have asked a dazzling array of
questions I think of the pioneers of
co-education fifty years ago in 1969 588
women came to study in the L College
they entered what had long been an
all-male institution and they asked
questions that hadn't been asked before
we will commemorate this milestone along
with a hundred and fiftieth anniversary
of women entering Yale's
School of Art throughout this year I
think of Margaret Warner class of 1971
an award-winning journalist she knows
how to ask brilliant questions and has
reported from war zones for decades
witnessing history firsthand trying to
understand our world I think two of
Alice young also class of 1971 she
looked around this campus and asked why
weren't there more students from public
schools so she became an ambassador for
Yale back in her home state of Hawaii
and she was one of the founders of the
Asian American students Alliance which
also celebrates its 50th anniversary
this year and we remember other
important anniversaries and the curious
students were part of these changes in
1969
thanks to student efforts the
afro-american cultural center known as
the house opened and what is now the
department of African American Studies
was created that same year students
established the Yale chapter of Mecca
and I believe we owe a debt of gratitude
a debt of gratitude to all the
courageous Pi
years throughout our history who have
made Yale what it is today what
questions will you ask how will your
questions transform Yale and improve the
world your time at Yale is an
unparalleled opportunity to engage with
a wide range of people ideas and
experiences more than at any other point
in your life you will have the means and
opportunity to hear from and converse
with world-renowned experts in many
fields you'll have the chance to create
knowledge through rigorous research and
attend arts literary and athletic events
that challenge and inspire you you will
spend time with peers whose lives have
been wildly different from your own what
if you nurtured your own curiosity by
pushing yourself beyond the familiar and
the comfortable what would that look
like for you it might be in attending a
talk on a topic you don't know much
about or by someone who doesn't share
your beliefs or conducting research in a
Yale laboratory or collaborating on an
exhibit at one of our amazing museums or
perhaps your curiosity will be sparked
by having coffee with a classmate who
comes from a different part of the world
or a different place on the political
spectrum and when you do these things
when you take advantage of the
opportunities Yale makes possible what
questions would you ask there is so much
we don't know let us embrace together
our humility our willingness to admit
what we have yet to discover after all
if you knew all the answers who would
not need yell and if humanity knew all
the answers the world would not need
yell so what questions will you ask
today tomorrow the next day and in the
days months and years after I have
shaken your hand at commencement let me
know let me know what questions you've
asked that have changed your life
good luck class of 2023
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my beloved Yale family as we ready
ourselves to step out onto new ground in
this daunting yet inspiring liminal
space of the unknown next we begin a
poignant turn of goodbyes and hellos
that invite laughter tears challenge
choice discovery and pride let us go
forth with deep trust in certain
knowledge that in this place each and
every one of you are welcome that in
this place we will both stumble and soar
that in this place love surrounds us
beauty can surprise us in this place
light and truth awaits us on this day
and every day forward may all that is
holy shine upon us and tenderly bless
our every breath may we go in Shalom in
Salaam in Shanti may we go in peace let
us begin
[Music]